وانا يعني عندي حفلتين اقسم بالله ال اكثر
من شهرين بدور بمب ما ملاقيه لهم حفي انا
قاعده بمز خيش من اعيه وبحط لحفيدتي وصار
عندها صار عندها من تحت التهابات مش
طبيعيه من قله البمبز ومن المعاناه اللي
احنا عايشينها يعني احنا بنروح نجلي على
الميه بلاقيش ميه نجلي بلاقيش ميه نتعقب
بلاقيش ميه نغسل وحتى لو بض ما بلاقيش
ارميها على ماما مش
عجبتني
على البمبر زمن بندوخ مش لاقين مقاسات
الاطفال هدول وبعدين ايش من اول الحربه
اللي يكرمك وهي معها اسهال مزمن ولا جايب
بالعلاج نتيجه ولا جايب شيء وطول النهار
نلف لا في مقاس اربعه ولا مقاس ثلاثه مقاس
اثنين وب 25 شيكل الباكيت ما بقعد عندها
يومين وضيق عليها على الاخر وصار عندها
التهابات في فخادها ومشاكل صحيه من قله
البمبرز الصحي الكويس وبعدين حتى في
المستشفى بطونا يعني راحت امها تجيب لها
عند ما بوصل الدور بقول لها خلصنا ثاني
يوم راحت قال انتلت الورقه خلص اخذنا
الاسماء بقيت البمبز يوصل 100 شيكل ما
بينفعش هذا حالنا مش حال هذا حالنا مش حال
علبه الحليب الاطفال ب 30 شي نشتريها
يسلموها من مكان ويبيعوا لنا اياها ناموا
بجوع وانا بنام في حضنهم بدموع عينيا يشهد
علي الله ما في اكل في قلب الخيمه اطعميه
لما ابني هلقيت تيجيني يقول لي يما بدي
اكل يما سقعان بدي جاكيته من وين انا اجيب
لهم ابوهم هيه مرمي في الخيمه رجله مقصو
نشح شحت من وين نجيب لهم بمبز والحليب
فرنا اه ب 30 شيكل لبه و عافيه صمو من
المدارس ويبيعو 30 شيكل يا خال وهعيط وبض
حليب وعيانين كمان يا اخو برضع منص ما فيش
مع اكل عجيب
حليب هناك معاناه شديده في
توفير البرز رقم ا خمسه وسته طبعا هذا
فاقم طبعا الامراض الجلديه عند الاطفال
والمعاناه بشكل كبير جدا خصوصا الارقام
هذه ذات شريحه كبيره عند
الاطفال معي طفلين بنت وولد وانا كمان
مصابه في العمود الفقري اربع فقرات عندي
مكسوره فبقدر اقوم يعني حاجات بسيطه وما
بقدر اعين اودي ووفر بدي توفروا لي بمبز
يعني بتوجه للجهات المختصه توفر لي بمبز
لاولادي وفروا لي هم بمبز ل مقاس صغير
فصار عندهم مشاكل وعنده التهابات وبيردوا
على حالهم زي هيك كمان طلبت براهم لهم
لانهم كثير يعني توجعوا من البمبز اللي
طلبوا لي اياه وفيش فش براهم متوفره في
هذا المستشفى فيهم ارب ايام ولا خ ass ah
ilm